il leur a donné rendez-vous dans un parc
à deux pas de leur université
[Musique]
Béto ou Rourke espèrent renverser le
gouverneur républicain et pour cela un
argument revient en boucle dans ses
discours face aux étudiants
grâce à grégabots notre actuel
gouverneur nous avons la législation la
plus extrême contre l'avortement aucune
exception même en cas de viol ou
d'inceste alors voilà ce que je crois
les femmes du Texas sont montré le
chemin il y a 50 ans elles vont regagner
leurs droits en 2022
dans la foule la révocation de l'arrêt
Reversus Wade qui garantissait le droit
à l'avortement au niveau fédéral a
profondément choqué
donc femme s'était effrayant de voir
dans quel monde envie désormais
ça n'empêche pas les avortements ça ne
fait qu'interdire ce pratiquer dans de
bonnes conditions avec le gouverneur
Abbot et les nouvelles restrictions à
travers le pays ça va faire du mal à
beaucoup de monde je pense que c'est une
raison de plus pour aller voter ce n'est
pas la seule mais c'est une raison
importante
le meeting se termine par une longue
séance de photos que les participants
pourront poster sur les réseaux sociaux
un bon moyen d'atteindre d'autres
électeurs et juste après vous êtes
inscrites pour faire du porte-à-porte
pour veto opération recrutement pour
aller convaincre des indécis c'est la
première fois que je vais faire du porte
à porte je suis vraiment contente de le
faire et j'ai l'impression qu'à Houston
il y a pas mal de gens modérés qui
peuvent basculer d'un côté ou de l'autre
et parfois juste avoir quelqu'un qui
fait l'effort de venir vous parler ça
peut faire pencher la balance pour le
candidat démocrate en retard dans les
sondages faire du droit à l'avortement
un pilier de sa campagne n'a rien
d'anodin et le Saad a eu un effet
mobilisateur sur l'électorat en
particulier chez les jeunes et surtout
chez les jeunes filles et ces électeurs
c'est la clé de la victoire mais le camp
démocrate n'est pas le seul à aller sur
ce terrain ce jour-là Austin alors qu'un
rassemblement pour le droit à
l'avortement débute une contre
manifestation s'organise une vingtaine
d'étudiants déroulent une banderole
anti-avortement
parmi eux Sarah militante depuis
l'adolescent l'avortement trahit les
femmes et les femmes méritent mieux
face à face deux camps très remontés à
l'approche de l'élection cela fait un an
que la loi sur le battement de cœur est
entré en vigueur et les femmes ne
meurent pas à cause de l'interdiction
d'avant
depuis la décision de la Cour suprême
chaque étape peut mettre en place ses
propres règles au Texas l'avortement
n'est possible qu'en cas de danger de
mort pour la mer encore insuffisant pour
ces militants même si
maintenant notre bataille au niveau de
chaque État et donc proposer des lois
locales sur la vie et la conception
interdire l'avortement par médicament ou
au premier battement de cœur c'est ce
que stude d'une folle en effet d'obtenir
étape par étape et au niveau national on
espère une interdiction totale de
l'avortement à l'avenir
à travers le Texas plus de la moitié des
23 cliniques pratiquant l'avortement ont
déjà fermé les autres ne sont ouvertes
que quelques heures par semaine
malgré ce qui ressemble à une large
victoire les militants conservateurs
poursuivent sans relâche le travail de
terrain
à la sortie de la messe dans cette
église du Nord d'Austin les fidèles en
grande majorité latino sont invités à
venir assister à une échographie
c'est un bébé de 17 semaines
l'examen est réalisé en direct juste
derrière l'écran et en face les enfants
sont assis au premier rang
et on peut voir voici le cœur vous voyez
le cœur qui bat
et là vous pouvez voir avec des couleurs
le sang qui passe dans le coeur du bébé
tout autour des participants des
associations anti-avortement qui
appuient le propos fascicule et fœtus en
caoutchouc à la pluie et puis
si on peut éduquer les gens qui n'ont
pas encore d'avis sur la question et les
convaincre que ces bébés qui sont
vivants sont en danger sibet
on pense que ce sera un facteur
déterminant pour qu'ils aillent voter
pour grégabots ou d'autres candidats
Provis
dans cet état un électeur sur cinq est
latino une communauté qui peut faire
pencher la balance et qui est donc
courtisé
aux abords d'un festival de musique
latine l'association mi familia vota
promeut la participation citoyenne et
pousse à s'inscrire sur les listes
électorales ceux qui ne sont pas encore
maintenant ça
prend un formulaire à remplir et les
volontaires s'occupent du reste
vous pensez en novembre
tant mieux et quand on demande ce qui
préoccupe les nouveaux inscrits le
principal sujet pour moi c'est
l'avortement je pense que les
gouverneurs ne devraient pas avoir leur
mot à dire sur ce que les gens font de
leur corps mais pour les personnes plus
âgées comme ma mère ou mon père ils sont
de l'ancienne génération pour eux
l'avortement va à l'encontre de
l'Évangile
des divergences au sein d'une communauté
souvent sous représentée dans les urnes
par manque d'inscription sur les listes
électorales
on nous assure nommé le géant dormi
chacun d'entre nous voter on pourrait
faire ou défaire une élection donc notre
vote est capitale
un enjeu majeur alors que plusieurs
études montrent que les femmes
hispaniques sont parmi les groupes les
plus touchés par l'interdiction
d'avorter